I think I'm actually gonna clear winner
here because who gets to just sit around
eating brownies all day hey everyone my
name is Brianna and I'm a pastry chef in
LA
I've worked in places from Bottega Louie
and John and Betty's and I also own my
own catering company called sugar and
spice say fry breeze today I am here to
review Fox brownie mix to see how it
stands up
when I eat a brownie I wanted to have
that nice crackly crumbly top fudgy in
the middle melts in your mouth and I'm
gonna use it in word it has to be moist
I'm going to start with Annie's based on
the box I had very low expectations
because the one on the box did not look
like this so I'm pleasantly surprised
okay maybe the nice gooey texture I can
see the little tiny chocolate chips that
they have in here it doesn't really give
me that
fudgy taste someone only use half the
amount of sugar they should have used
and 1/4 of the cocoa
next up mr. dough boy himself Pillsbury
it has that nice little crackle on top
we've even got some weird little bubbles
that happen this piece has exactly what
I want that nice fudgy Center nice
taking bottom
this has more cocoa flavor not quite a
tongue Majesta no it's kind of pinky
mr. dough boy kind of did his thing I'm
really loving that I have this crackling
table
dough boy you're doing good I'm ready to
move on to my best friend in my head
this Betty Crocker I don't have a fuzzy
Center that I would like I do see a
little bit of new and good goo in the
middle and it's clearly gooey enough to
fall apart
it looks very tanky more cakey and fudgy
maybe not that's got a great bite I get
some cocoa flavor but not too
overpowering but it's also not super
tangy miss Betty deceive me with these
looks I like it I get the crust I get
the moistness it's not super fudgy miss
Betty
good one here I'm by Duncan Hines hurt
regardless look whoever is responsible
for this it has the perfect crackly
topping it may not be good for your skin
but it's good and a brownie to see a
she's cracks and crumbles then the
inside is nice and moisturized this
clearly had a lot of lotion I hate to
say it but it's perfect the dark
chocolate here it gives me that slap
that punch of the face that I want it's
really well-balanced these are the
perfect fudgy texture onto the next one
we have here deli
it was the self-proclaimed premium
brownie mix I hope that they deliver on
appearance alone it looks amazing it's
dark chocolate so I know I'm going to
get that chocolate flavor I'm still
chewing so that's a great sign
it's fudgy it's gooey I love that they
had those huge chocolate chips in here
I'll get that crackling top and although
it fell apart into a million pieces it's
delicious it's smooth although it's
super chewy because of how fudgy it is
it kind of is silky on the tongue at the
same time kind of like a cheesecake I'm
happy with it
after more brownies than I care to
divulge and tell you I ate I'm finally
ready to pick a winner and Duncan Hawley
take the brownie cake on this one it was
everything I wanted it had the moistness
it had the flavor
it had the crackly crunching this on top
it is the supreme premium brownie base I
think it should take that title if you
don't want to use box mix and make them
from scratch I highly suggest finding a
recipe where you melt your chocolate
with your butter and then also add in
some instant espresso but it will really
heighten that cocoa flavor it just gives
you a nice little punch I'm going to go
make a brownie blanket and taking nice
long
you
[Music]